okay wonderful
okay welcome to the ddps seminar today
uh before we introduce today's speaker
uh let's go over some rules and
logistics first of all
please mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions
so that we our speaker can talk without
unnecessary interruption
if you have clarification questions you
are welcome to unmute yourself
and ask those questions otherwise please
use chatroom
to post your questions so that we can
address them
in q a session at the end of at the end
of the day
at the end of the talk today okay
second no classified discussion is
allowed here
so watch out finally the talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in in
our youtube channel okay
that's about the logistics now let me
introduce our speaker it is an
um great honor to foster today's speaker
professor cinesta
who is a full professor of computational
physics at
ensam institute of
technology in paris france honorary
fellow of the institute university
difference iuf and fellow of the spanish
royal academy of engineering he is the
president of the esi group scientific
committee
and the director of its scientific
department
he was airbus group chair
professor from 2008 to 2012
and since 2013 he is esi
group chair professor on advanced
modeling and simulation of materials
structures
process process processes and systems
he received many scientific words in
different fields bioengineering material
forming
processes rheology and computational
mechanics with major contributions in
modal order reduction and engineering
artificial intel
intelligence both integrated in the
so-called
hybrid paradigm of simulation-based
engineering it received many
distinctions
among them the academic terms the french
order of merit
in 2018 the doctorate honors
khalsa at the university of zaragoza
in spain and in night and in 2019 the
silver medal from the french
cnsr today professor chinese
will present empowering hybrid
twins from physics-informed artificial
intelligence which is very interesting
topic so uh please enjoy a wonderful
talk now without further ado let me pass
the button to professor sinasta
thank you thank you thank you very much
for your kind
introduction on the
i will i will present our most
recent works that we are performing in
the context of this chair
with esi group at rcmt institute of
technology
in a lab that is part of the cineres
that is the national science foundation
in france
so the title and poverty nightly twins
from physics inform artificial
intelligence and my co-author my main
co-author because there are many iscelia
from the university of zaragoza in spain
and
in one sentence in the century
or the the century of the arts
of modeling this means describing the
reality from equations
the art of simulation because these
equations are quite complex and we need
to solve this in a very efficient manner
and probably in this new a
millionaire in this new century we are
moving
from these two arts to a new one that is
the art of decision making
and taking a decision means tie the
right decision at the right time
and this is not easy and for that we
need very
powerful computational technologies
so i introduced the topic
because in the past engineers
create designs from simulation
now things are a little bit different
because we are trying to treat the more
and more
complex on very complex systems
very large and very uncertain
so this is the new the new domain
in which engineering applies we are not
only interested in defining these
systems
in designing these systems we are also
interested in
learning from the functioning of the
systems
monitoring in order to anticipate
we are very interested in diagnosis and
prognosis
and for that nothing new
we need to compute fast and very
accurate
and these two words fast and very
in the history in general these two
words
are quite difficult to put together
because when we are looking for a very
high accuracy
we take time in order to compute the
solutions
and when we are interested in moving
fast
we degradate simplify the models
and in this case the quality of the
solution is degraded
so this means that in principle this
objective
of having fast and accurate
is quite complex but is needed today
when we are treating for example a
nuclear reactor
or an airplane in that case you need to
compute very very fast
and you can you need to compute very
accurate solutions so this is the two
key words in my presentation today
is to create this alliance between these
two words
the word accurate and the word fast
and for that i'm using this fundamental
equation
this fundamental equation that writes
reality
the real the real world around us
is equal to the things that you know
the art of modeling the physics based
models
plus the things that you ignore
that we call the ignorance is all the
part
of the reality that is not in your
models
and obviously models are models
reality sometimes is a little bit more
complex
because the models is an idealization
of the reality but not the reality
itself
so finally reality is this combination
something that is coming from the
physics this is the knowledge
this is the art of modeling and
something that we ignore
something that is not in the model that
we call ignorance
and in order to be very accurate we are
trying to
create model based on physics
this is not new but we need to solve
them very very fast
and for that we are using model order
reduction that is one of the ingredients
of my
receipt and when
our predictions are not in agreement
with
them assurance this means that there is
a gap there is a deviation there is an
ignorance the idea is to take these
deviations
and create on the fly a model of that
deviation
and for that we are using only the
that means only data and we are
manipulating this data by using
machine learning so finally this
equation that appears in this slide
is a mix of physics mathematics
statistics data and
machine learning or artificial
intelligence
but we need to solve all these
very fast and very accurate and this is
something that we call the hybrid
paradigm
the hybrid engineering the hybrid twin
sorry so i will start with
solving the physics very fast this is
one of the two
the first part in this equation that i
just
discussed we would like to take the
model based on physics
and we would like to show these models
in real time
why because we need to take decisions
very very fast
and we need to consider the existing
knowledge the existing models
but i need to solve them very very fast
in order to take
very fast decisions and for that
we are using model order reduction and
in particular
one technology that we are developing
for many years
that we call proper generalized
decomposition
there are many others the pod the
reduced basis
there are plenty of them for me there is
not a question the hour is better than
the others no this is not the case
the hour is one possibility and this
possibility runs
well with the cases that we are treating
but there is not
a question of
trying to put this before
the others so what is the proper
generalized decomposition
this is quite simple in general we are
using this technique in order to
circumvent the course of dimensionality
in
multi-parametric models what is a
multi-parametric model this is the first
question in this slide you have a
differential operator
that is acting on the unknown field u
and u depends on a space x on time t
and it depends on a series of parameter
mu
1 to mu m and f
is the loading term in this
model in order to
circumvent the course of dimensionality
our idea is to introduce all the
parameters
as extra coordinates
this means we are trying to solve this
problem for any possible value of the
parameters mu 1 to mu
m in the same way that we are trying to
compute
u that contains the information at each
point
and at each time and for this this is a
nice idea
because if mu 1 to mu m are extra
coordinates
as soon as i compute u function of
x t mu 1 mu m
i know the solution of my problem for
any choice of the parameter
and this is very nice because as soon as
you have a parametric solution
we can optimize we can simulate we can
make inverse analysis we can propagate
uncertainty
we can make control all them in real
time
because we pre-compute the solution for
any choice of the parameters
so we are very interested in computing u
for any choice of the parameter
and for that reason the parameters are
not more parameters they are
extra coordinates like the space
like the time and finally
the problem of adding all these
parameters as extra coordinate
is one problem that was 3d transient now
with 3d transient
and many other dimensions
that are coming from the parameters and
we have obviously in that case
the so-called course of dimensionality
in order to avoid this course of
dimensionality the idea is to use the
separation of variables
that establish that a function that
depends on x
t mu 1 mu m can be written
or approximated by a sum from 1 to
capital
n of capital m functions
x i functions of x capital
n functions t i functions of t
and after many functions p
i for each one of the coordinates
mu g so finally the separation of
variables is nice
because a problem that is highly
multi-dimensional
can be written as a sum
of problems that
involves functions each one
of very low dimensionality functions
x are 3d functions t
are these functions
p i g r one d
depending on the parameter in the
coordinate
mu g so this is the advantage of using
the separation of variables and when you
are using this separation of variables
we call it
proper generalized decomposition because
it's
like a proper orthogonal decomposition
but we have not
orthogonality the reason we call it
yi degeneralize so it's a sort of
decomposition like the pod
but in this case there are many other
functions that concern the parameter
and obviously the constructor that we
are using
is not an orthogonal basis and for that
reason we call it
pgd proper generalized decomposition
so in order to construct this
approximation this separated
approximation of mayano
u we are using some ingredients the
first one is we are computing a model at
a time
and we call it a greedy rank one update
at this time we compute one term in this
sum
that contains capital n terms
the second one is this time that we are
computing one obviously we have the
product of
unknown functions x t p
and in order to solve this nonlinear
problem we are using an alternate
direction fixed point and as soon as all
this is defined
we put this u in this operator we are
using a standard alerting or petrol
alert in
weak form and we proceed
in a standard manner in order to compute
each one of these functions involving
this separated approximation
so this is beautiful but the problem of
all this is
is highly intrusive when you are trying
to introduce this kind of representation
in an existing software and for the
reason
even if we publish many many papers on
this technology
the intrusive pgd is very difficult
to implement in the existing shower for
that reason
we move to alternative approaches
and one of them is based on meta
modeling what means metamodeling this is
the response faces and the idea is to
define
a parametric space this is all the
parameters in the model
these blue dots represent the choice of
the parameters the design of experiment
for each one of these points we are
running a high
fidelity solution in order to obtain
the solution related to each one of
these choices in the parameters
we obtain a solution a transient
solution in general
that we can pre-compress in order to
extract the space
modes and the time modes in this image
are the blue vector and the red vectors
unlike this you can compact the high
fidelity transient solutions
in few vectors in space and few modes in
time
and for that you can use the pod the pgd
the cure the aim the cross-approximation
many many technologies in order to
compress
these very big matrices
and as soon as this is ready and again
following the rationale of the
a separation of variables now that we
have the mods in a space at the most in
time
if each one of this solution is related
to a point in the parametric
space the only thing that we need is to
add
new modes in the parametric dimensions
and finally the good news is when you
perform the sum
of the tensor product of the modes in a
space
the most in time and the modes in the
parameter
you obtain a kind of cube and when you
have many parameters
an e per cube in which each point
represent the solution at a given point
at a given time
and for any value of the parameter
so finally we are making a sort of
regression
of these solutions in the parametric
space
and to make the regression we are using
advanced
nonlinear regressions that is one of the
tools that are
very common in machine learning and for
that
we try and we industrialize and
i present some results a little bit
later
many alternatives we know the polynomial
regression
the polynomial regression if is linear
is too
poor and if you increase the degree
and the points are not the gauss love a
touch of checkpoint you can have this
kind of
overfitting obviously you can use
orthogonal polynomials like in the case
of the so-called
ssl in which because these points are
distributed as the collocation points
you can obtain by using an orthogonal
approximation basis
very nice approximations but the problem
of that is
you need a grid for the collocation
points and this
explodes when you are increasing the
number
of dimensions and in our case the number
of dimensions is the number of
parameters and the number of parameters
is quite higher
tens tens or even more
so for that reason we decide to use
sparsity
and when we are using sparsity at a
double level
the first sparsity is because we are
using a sparse sampling
and this is for example by using the
hypercube latin the latin
the latin nipper cube the second
sparsity is
because obviously when you are using
field data and your solution is
extremely non-linear
if you are using nothing finally your
equation your solution deviates from
the reference one in order to improve
the accuracy
the idea is to use a basis
that is very rich and trying to take
only the
right elements in order to approximate
the function
and this is the sparse regularization
that we can use in the elastic net like
a combination of rich
and lasso or a pure lasso
regularization that we call diver
sparse pgd because there is a sparse
sampling and there is the sparse
regularization
obviously this is not new sparse
regularization has been applied
many many times but the only thing that
we add
as something new is this sparsity
is combined with the separation of
variables
and this is the good news today because
we need a separation of variables in
order to address
highly multi-dimensional problems and we
are using the sparsity
in order to take only the
right functions in the approximation
basis in order to approximate the
solution
avoiding overfitting and
obviously in order to make this we need
to combine this
s par regularization with the separation
of variables and
our most important
contribution combining these two
ingredients separation of variables
and sparse regularization
and with all this the good news is in
order to solve a problem that contains
p parameters we are using in the order
of p
data and we obtain solutions that are
quite reasonable with respect to the
industrial needs and very
recently we are using exactly the same
thing but we are using
a kind of quadrature that is
close related to the anova the analysis
of variance
and the good news here is there are also
a polynomial approximation by using
orthogonal polynomials and this is also
a good new
because finally by combining everything
the separation of variables the alice of
variance
and the star regularization we obtain
very very accurate approximations
by using very few data
and this is very important for us
because when we are trying to use data
the data is not so abundant and we need
to create
very efficient regressions in order to
adjust the models
from the data but obviously when there
are many many dimensions
and there is low in the low
data limit and this is the main
center of interest of the techniques
that we are proposing
and sometimes again in order to improve
the accuracy we are trying to take all
the solutions that we complete compute
offline related to different choices of
the parameter
and instead of creating a regression for
all the simulations
we decide to make some clustering
to clusterize these solutions and to
apply
in each one of the clusters a regression
and as soon as all this multiregression
is ready
this means that in the future when
someone
send me the choice of the parameters i
need to identify by using a
classification the cluster to which
these parameters belong and we can take
the
regression related to the cluster c
and i can particularize this regression
for the choice
of the parameters so this is the
technology
based on advanced nonlinear regressions
that operates in
multi-dimensional settings at the
low data limit and
in order to show you few examples
you can see here one problem that is
related to the crash
externally non-linear there is dynamics
there is elastoplasticity there is
damage there is fracture
and the idea is to consider a very a
rich model with more than 5 million
elements
there are more than 20 parameters each
calculation
takes days or weeks and
this means that we cannot perform many
many
simulations and the idea is when we have
about
20 we would like to compute solution
with about 20 runs
and for that reason we are using the
technologies that i just introduced in
order
to compute the parametric solution and
now as soon as
you can change one of the parameters you
can see what is the impact in the
solution
here on the right on the bottom you can
see a welding process
many parameters again the power the
velocity and the welding etc
and as soon as this parametric solution
has been compute
now you can change the parameter you can
move the parameter with these sliders
and you can observe the impact of each
one of the parameters
in the quantity of interest that you are
representing in this solution
so finally you spend a little bit of
time in constructing this parametric
solution
this surface
response surface but finally is not too
expensive
because we are using this separation of
variables combined
with the sparse regularization and with
this we have something that is quite
accurate and very very fast
to a to compute here you have another
example
this is an airbag and you are trying to
simulate the ironbag
folding you can fold it to put in a
small box
that is in your car you can unfold
and now there are many parameters some
ones related to the size of the ipad
orders that are related to the geometry
of the box
and you can again to fall unfold
and this is not the videos game so this
is the real physics this is the
membrane or shell element with contact
there are millions of contacts
so there is a phase in which we are
computing the solution for different
choice of the parameters
and after we are using these
technologies
these regression technologies combining
the separation of variables
and sparsity in order to compute these
metamodels
and now you can apply this in many
domains like in thermal comfort
you have your car you have the driver
and now you can introduce many
parameters in this case is the flow rate
and the external temperature
and by moving these sliders you can
observe or you can
evaluate the conditions inside
this is for thermoforming in
polypropylene
and now you have here your parameters we
create by using this technologies
the responsive phase and now by moving
this
slider you can evaluate the impact here
you have a crash
a real one for the yaris in
which you have the impact of different
parameters that are the thicknesses of
the different metallic sheets
that we are using in the structure and
you can see
by moving the different parameters in
real time you can
evaluate the impact of these parameters
in the solution
and this one is for the external
aerodynamics in the turbulent flow
and here the parameters are this angle
and
the size of the obstacle and finally we
are again
making a sampling and sparse sampling
and computing by using the separation of
variables
and something related to the sparse
regularization so this is the
technologies that we are using
sometimes we need to combine
with optimal transport because you can
understand that if in a problem
for one parameter you have the blue
curve and for the other the orange curve
if you take a parameter that is in the
middle finally you interpolate
you will have the half of this and the
half of this
and you would like to have something
that is the half ball located in the
middle
and for that we need to combine all the
regression that i had
this used combined with the optimal
transport that is a kind of an
interpolation in a lagrangian sense
and by containing all these now you are
changing the orientation in this
ventilation device and you can observe
what is
the velocity field of the air inside
the cabin so this is the technologies
that we are using
and now the next step is and what
happens
if finally we have the parameters but
the parameters are not deterministic
the parameters are stochastic and for
making this
that is imagine this problem in which we
have this
specimen these coupons we are making
attraction
a test and the behavior law of these
coupons follow this very well-known
constitutive equation but k epsilon 0
and n are has a stochastic distribution
so finally are not parameters we need
in order to propagate uncertainty or to
make
robustness analysis we need to take in
consideration that this k
epsilon 0 and n are distributions
and not values so the first is sample
a design of experiments for any choice
of k
epsilon 0 and n we have a traction curve
and the idea is as soon as you compute
your parametric solution
now the parameters are not k
epsilon 0 and n are the average
and are the standard deviation and as
soon as you compute this
this is the parametric solution at the
beginning
k epsilon 0 and n
are given values and we can see that we
can interpolate
the solution by changing some parameter
the traction curve is moving
but the good news is is a certain moment
sorry if a certain moment
we start to introduce a variance
in the distribution of the parameters we
compute this kind of corridors
that give you with 95 percent of
probability
that the resulting curve traction curve
is inside and the point at which
the specific the specimen breaks
is in between this corridor that is the
vertical one
so this is a way that is quite simple
from a parametric solution
to present the same results but
in a statistical way this is another
case but it's not necessary that we move
in and finally the main message is
when we have components we can use this
framework
this workflow we can compute the
parametric solution and finally in this
landing
device finally you can compute
the stresses depending on
the loading and it depends on the
landing conditions
so finally this is a very expensive
calculation but we are computing this in
a parametric way
by changing the different efforts that
we are applying to this system
and the good news is after you can take
it because this is
a responsive phase and you can couple
this responsible phase
in a system engineering modeling and
this is good news because now the draw
leak or the electrical system can be
combined with the high fidelity finite
element simulations
and you can manipulate in real time
engineering system in which each
component
is high fidelity because you are using
the parametric solution that you compute
by using
this methodology and you arrive that the
system is no more like a lego
in which you are combining the
components and each component that is
parametric
is the allocating with the other
component
unlike this we can move from the
component to the system
or to the system or systems
so until now i prove that
using this kind of technologies we can
obtain
quite accurate
solutions of the model that we are
considering
but now we have a problem we are solving
very very fast
the models that are expected describing
the reality
but only expected describing
probably their reality is much more
rich and this means that we can solve
very very fast
our models but maybe
these solutions are quite far from the
reality
so now we are moving to the second part
this is not only solving fast
the idea is to solving well the idea is
to obtain predictions that are very
close to the reality
and for that as you remember at the
beginning in this fundamental equation
we write that the reality is our models
that now we can solve very very far by
using all these methodologies that i
described the model order reduction or
the metamodels
from the sure the things that you want
and the idea now is
even if i can solve very fast if my
solution is
not very good and there is a deviation
an important deviation with respect to
the reality
i enrich my model and in order to enrich
the model i will take the deviation the
ignorance the gap
and i would like to use machine learning
in order to online create a model
of the gap and this is very important
because finally
if we can manipulate physics in real
time and i can create
models of the ignorance in real time
when we put both together
i will represent the reality very well
very well and very fast in order to make
this
we are trying to make machine learning
and the idea is now is not only
responsive faces
i would like to create models from this
gap
and i would like that all these models
that we are creating
are also fulfilling the fundamental
equations
in mechanics this means for example
energy conservation
entropy production symmetries
etc and for making that we start from
classical analytic mechanics in which
you have the axiom you have the
lagrangian
you have the hamiltonian that is the
legendre transformation of the light of
the lagrangian
and finally you have a very nice context
that obviously
is only in hamiltonian mechanics when we
are moving to irreversible
thermomechanics we need also to
introduce the dissipation and for that
in collaboration with alias cueto from
zaragoza we are trying to
implement the genetic framework that is
something in the thermodynamics of
irreversible systems
in which the state of the system evolves
in time
from a part that is the hamiltonian part
with l
the antisymmetric matrix this is the
gradient
in the phase state of the hamiltonian
and one matrix
that is symmetric and positive definite
that is semi-definite that is
the dissipation matrix and you have the
gradient
in the first space of the entropy
with some conditions the dissipation
don't affect the hamiltonian and the
hamiltonian don't create
entropy and with these conditions that
can be written in a discrete form
you can learn models that
conserve the energy and produce the
entropy and this is very important
to be conservative and to be stable
and for that the production of the
entropy is a key
issue and by using these technologies
the idea is to use an estate that could
be very very large
we are using a newton coder in order to
encode and to find the intrinsic
dimensionality
of the state of the system after we
introduce this
a part of thermodynamically consistent
neural network
and after we have the decoder in order
to
come back to the standard space
state and when we are applying this
we are creating models that has all the
right
properties and in this video from the
team in zaragoza you can see
we are trying to learn in a
thermodynamically consistent way
the movement of a fluid in a
in a glass obviously the different fluid
with different rheologists with
different viscosities the movement
is not exactly the same but we learn
from this information we apply
some filters in particular related to
the tda the topological data analysis
we create this kind of models in order
we are enforcing or we are
learning a model that to fulfill the
thermodynamics
and now you can see the water does not
exist we are putting it inside
the glass and now we can move
recipient the container and we can
introduce
virtually the fluid inside and we can
reproduce
quite well the movement the dynamics of
this fluid
and everything is consistent from a
thermodynamical
point of view so this is the advantage
of
learning in a framework that is
consistent with thermodynamics
first because integration is stable
second
because as soon as you introduce physics
in the learning
you need much less data that if you are
working on creating the model from
scratch
and now the idea is we can put both
together
we have the analogic
word in the past and we we have the
build 12 prototypes that is the physics
we can solve physics in real time
because we have model order reduction
we can introduce this in a system
modeling so this is
physics in real time in a system
modeling as i presented at the beginning
and
this is the classical virtual twin based
on physics
now if there is a gap between our
predictions and the measurements
the idea is to take this real data in
our cases the gap
is the deviation we would like to make
data analytics in real time to create
this machine learning that create these
models that
fulfill the thermodynamic consistency
and as soon as this model is ready
you can introduce also in the system
modeling that you have a kind
of digital twin of the deviation and
when you put
the virtual twin the physics plus the
model of the deviation
you obtain something that is very close
to the reality
in order to illustrate it imagine this
case in the lab
we are feeling this mold this is a
composite
preform this is the resin that is moving
inside
there is of course there is a model we
know that the fluid is in the domain
omega
that this point in the fluid domain is x
that in the fluid domain there are two
variables that are very important the
pressure and the velocity
and we know from physics that the
velocity is minus the permeability
gradient of the pressure
this is coming from the dash's law that
is very well known
is a very nice approximation and we have
the fluid conservation that implies that
the divergence of the velocity field is
equal to zero
and when we are combining both we obtain
that the divergence of k multiplied by
the gradient of pressure
is equal to zero and this is something
that is implemented in
in many commercial solver so we take
this commercial shower in our case where
spam rtm from esi group
and by solving this equation for many
value of the co-permeability
we compute the position of the flow from
depending on the parameter
k and now as soon as we compute this by
using the metamodeling that i described
at the beginning
now for a large permeability medium or
any small
you can see the effects in the filling
process when the permeability is very
large the filling is very fast
and when it's very low the permeability
the filling process is very
very slow so finally
here there is only the post processing
because this is the parametric solution
but as i have access to the simulation
in real time for any value of the
permeability
now in the reality as soon as this fluid
is moving
i could try to interrogate my parametric
solution in order to try
to obtain the permeability that allows
to predict a fluid
volume a volume of fluid that is in
agreement
with the experience and from this
minimization i can obtain
in real time the permeability
and you can see here in few seconds
my simulation and my experience is in
perfect agreement
because at the first time instance i
obtain
by using an inverse technique the value
of the permeability in order to make
that my simulations are in agreement
with the experience
so until now this is only physics
physics in real time but there is not
artificial intelligence
what is the problem the problem is
imagine in this case
i calibrate very very fast and the
physics is wonderful
my predictions are exactly the same that
the experiments so i'm very happy
but but but there is an ignorance that
is coming
because after a certain time the
experiment is absolutely different than
my simulation
why because in the experiment the
permeability close to the wall of the
domain
is very low and finally you can see this
is the ignorance
something that exists in the reality
that is not in my numerical model
and this ignorance is in fact the
deviation
that i will notice imagine now
the hybrid paradigm as soon as the
model is enough everything is okay i
don't need to make things
my simulation is perfect but if at a
certain moment
my experiment changed my simulation
adapt
why because we added to the darcy's
model
the model of the gap the model of the
gap that we compute by using a
regression
on the difference between the prediction
and the measurements and this is the
idea of the ivory twin
we have a model we are solving this
model in real time
if everybody is everything is okay we
don't need
to make things by using other
technologies but if a certain moment
my simulation does not correspond to the
reality
i try to use this deviation in order to
be treated by using machine learning
online in order to create the model of
the enrichment such is that
the moderation physics plus the model of
the deviation
represent the reality and now
as soon as this works we can move to the
more complex cases
only two slices and i finish my
presentation
in this case this is an electrical car
i create a model of the battery i learn
by using the regressions the state of
charge and the voltage depending on the
current that we
demanded to the battery and we can
introduce these models
into the engineering system
and now we have the representation of
the car
and now we can connect with openstreet
or with google maps
and i can introduce i would like to move
from a to b
and i can predict during
the time the evolution of the state of
charge or the voltage in this case
and obviously this is the nominal but
when we
start to the real itinerary
there is a deviation because in general
the things that you will
experience in the reality is a little
bit different to the things
that you expected in your prediction
and as soon as this different applies
the idea is to
start with modeling this difference
in order to keep your system always in
control
and this is one of the advantages last
example
this is coming from the aviation
in this case they have a model a little
bit simplified
of the a system in this airplane
and the question is as this model is a
little bit simplified when we compare
the prediction with the
sensors the result is not good enough
what is the idea
we use this model this model make
predictions
and we compare the predictions with the
measurements and we make the difference
if a difference exists this means that
there is a gap
an ignorance there is something in the
system that is not in the model
and at this moment this difference
is we create a model of this difference
by using
a regression for example a neural
network or any kind of regression that i
introduced at the beginning
and as soon as you create this model you
have the model of the difference
if you have the model of the difference
and you have the model the nominal model
if you put both together you will obtain
the predictions that are
imperfect or almost perfect agreement
with the measurements so finally this
is the ivory paradigm the knowledge
materializing a physics-based model this
one
can be enriched with a data-driven model
of the gap between predictions and
measurements
and when you put both together in this
operation
you obtain the physical reality so now
data serves in order to make diagnosis
directly from the data in order to
enrich
the model by using this hybrid paradigm
and when you obtain a very nice
prediction
of the model you can start to make
prognosis
i have no time to introduce this concept
that is
based on data and i will finish with
now that we can obtain
a real replica of the real physics
we consider this sentence that is quite
impressive
people remember very differently what
they
learn after two weeks 10 to 20 percent
of what
they hear or read 90
of what they did so this means
that finally we need to touch we need to
experience the reality even if the
reality is virtual and for that again
elias cuerto and his group in zaragoza
by using all the technologies that i
describe
based on physics based on data based on
the
implication of these tools we create a
sort of interaction
with a virtual world you have the
standard
the stand for money you have that is
virtual
you have an office that is real and we
pre-compute
all the interaction all the possible
interaction by using contact mechanics
in inter-elastic materials
and now as soon as this is ready now you
can start to
interact with the bunny and here
we are using contact mechanics and we
are using
the deformation in large deformation of
these perilastic materials
this is for the stamp for dragon and now
you can touch
virtually obviously because it does not
exist
you can in real time experience the
deformations
you can superpose the displacement field
the stresses the deformations
and after is you need to to cheat from
other
from other directions you can touch and
you can appreciate
in all the cases the very nice
performances and this is more or less
the same a recent work of elias and the
team
in which they are making something
similar but now by using
in this case the the the the
holography and now you can see
nothing new the stamp for bonnie the
modes and now you are see here
the bunny that appears the holography
and now you can touch it you can touch
obviously at this moment we have not the
the sensation of the
touch is coming but finally you can now
interact with a virtual world
and you have the real time and you have
the right
deformations because everything is
coming
from the equations of physics that we
manipulate
by using model order reduction in real
time and
when needed we can enrich by using the
deviation
and construct
we are trying to move toward an hybrid
intelligence
we have to reach performances by design
in order to augment
humans we are trying now to introduce
multi-sensorial and emotional in this
interaction between the real and the
virtual world
in order to empower obviously humanism
and all this in this new world of the
decision making for a more resilient war
in which we are trying to create
an alliance between these two key words
that was accurate and fast so
in order to be accurate the idea is
to take all the knowledge the physics
and
if it's not enough we are trying to
create by using machine learning the
model
of the deviation the gap and when we put
both together
this approximate better than reality and
this is
our hybrid paradigm so this from one
side
and to process very very fast the idea
is to use
this modal order reduction in order to
compute
all the possible solutions because all
the parameters are
extra coordinates and today we can
create
responses we can create parametric
solutions
in highly multi-dimensional parametric
spaces even in the low
data limit by using this advanced
regression technologies that we
introduced just
at the beginning and this
is all from my side thank you very much
and the you have the record
video and if you need because there are
so many slides that i have no time to
present
related to the topological data analysis
uh i could transfer also my power point
to the tudor system thank you very much
thank you so much professor sinasta
there was a
very nice demonstration about the distal
twins
and why we need a
you know the model of the reductions and
machine learning
for the ultimate decision making
applications there was
very nice demonstrations i really
enjoyed it
um so let's have some q and a sessions
um
yep um if if and
so i don't see any questions from the
chat room so uh
please feel free is there is one
question from the chat
there is one question from the chat that
is
do you assume a statistical distribution
to account for the difference
between the model predictions on the
reality
at this moment no i suppose that there
is a deterministic reality an
undeterministic
model and finally we are created
but in other cases we consider
that the model is not deterministic as
you remember at the beginning when we
treat the
the tensile the traction test we can
introduce
that the parameters of the model is also
stochastic
and instead of having only one model we
have a corridor
and we have the model inside the
corridor
and in other cases when you are have a
sensor
the sensor is not giving a value the
sensor has
also a variance and in that case
when you are taking different values in
the sensor
you need to consider that this is also
statistic
values it's a stochastic and now finally
you have
a kind of corridor for the data and a
kind of corridor
for the model the idea is to create a
model
that relates the average of the model
with the average of the data
and that can also standard deviation of
each one
so this is not in my presentation there
is not
i don't consider this but in the reality
the model is a corridor this is an
interval
because you have an average and you have
a
standard deviation around and the same
for the data
so when you are creating the model we
are creating a model in order to align
the average behavior and we are creating
a model in order to our
environment
okay thank you so much any other
questions from
the chat okay awesome thank you
um okay so we just got another questions
from
ian for your pgd based
emulators the number of training
sampling points are order number of
parameters correct
if you recall how many sample points
were used
to build a 20 parameter card deformation
for example
yes yes yes yes yes the idea
is it depends on the technology that we
use
for example if we are using the
collocation points in the ssl
imagine that you are in the lowest level
you have one in the mean and one in the
max this is nice
min and max there are two two per
dimension
when you create the tensor product if
you have 10 dimensions
you need 2 power 10. so finally it's
excellent
this technology but finally the number
of points
in the sampling increase exponentially
with the number of dimensions
when we are using the sparse the idea in
the sparse is
i put many functions in my basis
and i asked to find for the ones
that in the sparsest sense can
approximate the data
and for making this as you can see in
this slide
the sparse sampling the number of runs
is about or similar or very close
to the number of parameters in this case
that i introduced here
that is something that we developed for
volkswagen gestam renault mitsubishi or
hyundai if there are 20 parameters
i make only 20 rounds but
20 parameter 20 runs does not mean that
i'm making a linear regression
i'm making a strongly non-linear
regression because we are regularizing
by using the sparsity so finally
we have about the same number in this
applications
the same number of runs that the number
of parameters
but we obtain nonlinear regressions
because our space of approximation is
very large
and i take only the functions by using
this
spar regularization so this is
separation of variables a sparse
sampling the same number of points that
the number of parameters
more or less plus the sparse
regularization a sparse or rich elastic
net
so we are using kind of regular
decisions in order to select
the right functions and avoid
overfitting
this is the idea
okay thank you so much um yeah i i
myself
was puzzled about that too like
i mean i understand what you're doing
but it's hard to believe that
only the 20 sample points uh within uh
in the 20 the parameter parameter
space dimension was giving you a
good enough accuracy in as you
demonstrated in the
car uh the hyundai car example yeah um
i i definitely need to looking more into
that
yes yes yes yes yes yes
there is no miracle the idea is if the
solution that approximate the reality
is in my approximation basis and i'm
using
an sparse stability and spar
regularization
obviously the interest is to take the
function that
could with only one function represent
all the data
this is the idea in a spar
regularization
if you take an infinity of functions
imagine
all the functions you introduce in your
approximation function
is sure that when you take 10 points
these 10 points are all them
on the solution that exist in my basis
so the idea is there is one that is able
to represent all the data
if i introduce a star regularization and
i take exactly this function
with only one function i can represent
all the data obviously
we have not an infinity of functions in
my basis
and obviously with the spa
regularization are not finding exactly
the best one
so finally is not so optimal but the
idea is this one
the idea is if my basis is very rich
the solution is inside and if we are
something that is
able to take it with only one function i
can represent my solution
so for the reason we are using not too
many points
more than using many many points the
idea is to use many many functions in
approximation basis
and to have something that is robust to
treat a lot of dimensions
this is the separation of variables and
something that select the right function
and this is the star regularization
wonderful okay uh another question
can you have a follow up on this one
yeah yeah go ahead i mean but
yeah this are you familiar with the
cindy though uh
yes yes yes yes exactly exactly this is
this
is this is the cindy the nathan kutz
the only thing that we make is we put
this in a tensor format
because we are using as you can see here
we are using this sorry i'm i
i arrive we are using this in the
separation of variable but it's exactly
the same
is the same regularization but we are
taking to take this
in different directions because we are
making the separation of variables
great but john john i i i get stereo to
your question right
yes the question that cindy was my
question but i was wondering how do you
build the library of databases you must
have good physical knowledge to actually
propose a library of function before you
make the selection
exactly one possibility is when we have
not information
we take a very rich polynomial basis
or like in the cindy we can put a
harmonic functions exponential all the
things that you want
but from an industrial point of view
when we are applying this in industrial
problems and this is the advantage
i arrived in my presentation when we are
treating this kind of problems we have a
lot of simulations
so this means that we have very nice
candidates to put them
in the uh in the bases so this is one
advantage
because finally we need to correct
things that exist
because finally there are thousands
of runs that exist and this is the
knowledge that exists in the industry
so we can improve obviously the choice
of the basis
when we have not information we take a
basis that is
rich enough and the anova is another
choice that is very representative
because we are looking for the functions
that depends only in one of the
parameters
and in order to compute i come back i
come back i come back
sorry is coming this one
and when you are using the anova the
advantage in the anova is
all the functions are orthogonal
and when you are considering all these
functions all these points there is only
one coordinate that is changing
all the others are constant and now you
can obtain a very non-linear function
in each one of these dimensions and this
means that all the things that are
related to each one of the coordinates
not to the coupling but to this
coordinate independently of the others
you can obtain a very rich and extremely
non-linear function
and as soon as this is okay now you add
some
green points and with the green points
you are only
trying to approximate all the
correlations between the different
dimensions
so we are using anova for the function
that depends only
on one parameter and one function one
variable
and after we are using the green point
that is an sparse sampling
in order to obtain all the correlations
between the different dimensions
thank you thank you so much um
any other question from the audience
yeah yes i have one you you don't have
to read it i can just ask it
okay yeah go ahead this this is not a
technical question necessarily but
if we still have time and no one else
has a question some people are still
hesitating in
embracing model order reduction and
sometimes they call it just
you know a smarter interpolation
technique you know
they want to dismiss it this way what do
you reply to those people
yes i i think i think
i agree with them i agree with them is
model order reduction yes it's a
star reduced model but we are not
operating but projection and introducing
this
in the differential operator
or the reduction at the beginning was
this slide we're
using an approximation of my variable we
are in a reduced basis obviously because
there are many
many a number of terms we put in the
in the in the in the operator in the in
the in the operator in the differential
operator
we project and we compute the solution
this is the classical model order
reduction like in the pod
like in the reduced basis or like in the
pgd
now this is okay now the idea is and
what is this
this is this is a smart interpolation
this i like this i like this this is
a metamodel a surrogate model but you
can also
write this problem in this slide the
regressions
like this one but in this case l is the
identity operator
there are no derivatives but it's the
same i would like to approximate
something that i know by something that
has a separator representation
and in this case we are making a pgd
there are no differential operators this
is an identity operator and we are
computing the different functions
x t and p so for me the work is exactly
the same
in one case we could call it model order
reduction because we are assuming
a reduced approximation of a function
and we are trying
to compute this function by making a
projection alerting a non-galerkin
and in the case in this case we could we
we could call it
as a smart interpolation or
interpolation i i totally agree
but for me this is also in this setting
but now the differential operator is the
identity but
no problem for me for me we call colleet
model order reduction we are working in
the weak
or a strong form of a partial
differential equation
and this yes this is metamodeling this
is model order reduction this is
interpolation
i'm not uh every everything is right
it's not it's not an issue for me but
there's a confusion i agree with you
there are many people that
are assuming that this is metamodeling
yes this is metamodeling
but this is regression and regression is
machine learning so machine learning
linear regression is a technique of
machine learning all these
yes are regressions and i'm not sure if
this is model or
resolution this is machine learning this
is regression
i don't know i don't know thank you so
much
for the answer thank you very much thank
you
thank you for the question too um okay
any other questions well
um if if not let's um
let's thank our speaker
paco the professor chinese